me dire et puis demain après cette
édition de 20h qui vous sera présenté
par béatrice schönberg maigret revient
le commissaire maigret voit double c'est
le titre du nouvel épisode avant de
recevoir bruno cremer voyons une petite
rétro composé par frédéric bonnet sur
ceux qui endossent r le paletot du
commissaire créé par simon
voilà on a eu pas si je rêvais que je me
rasais se tourne bien moi aussi je suis
de bonne humeur commissaire maigret
cette carte tricolore va permettre
amaigri de découvrir la double
personnalité de la victime
cette nouvelle adaptation respecte à la
lettre l'esprit des aventures du célèbre
personnage de simenon lui qui pénètre
tous les milieux sociaux sans exception
y compris ce quartier du xvième où nous
avons appris qu il est un des rares
héros a analysé le geste criminel le
crime humaine importe peu ce qui est
intéressant dans les maigres et c'est
pourquoi ils ont tué pourquoi ils ont
sans arriver là pourquoi tout d'un coup
dans des vies très calme et assez plat
et une faille
cette méthode mais green l'a toujours
respecté et même s'il se cacher derrière
les visages dit lustres comédiens comme
pierre renoir en trente deux albert
préjean michel simon où jean gabin on a
toujours reconnu maigret fort monsieur
ça sera un ami à la pression je sais que
la bière fait grossir avec le job est
annoncé mais j'ai préféré renoncer à la
coquetterie un hall de gare comme il les
aime et un témoin qui l'a bien
fréquentées mais grillons et 70 ans
aujourd'hui ce magistrat peut nous dire
si jules maigret n'est vraiment qu'une
invention maigret est le reflet de la
société de son temps donc il existe mais
maigret n'est pas un personnage
policiers vraisemblable c'est d'ailleurs
maigret est un véritable démiurge si
vous signez certains romans je pense
notamment un maigret aux assises vous
vous rendez compte que maigret va
laisser commettre sous nos yeux un crime
on voit bien qu'il n'ait pas comme les
autres notre maigret un commissaire qui
laisse échapper le coupable c'est plutôt
au suspect et puis on croit le connaître
et on le redécouvre encore à chaque
nouvel épisode il sait nous surprendre
c'est à croire que simenon lui même ne
le connaissais pas vraiment